bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors fini le masque en
extérieur dès aujourd'hui comment a
réagi la plus précieuse de trouver les
ce qu'elle se promène sans problème sans
masque parce que c'est comme difficile
de se réhabituer après de longs mois de
restriction vous remercie d'avoir
aujourd'hui manifestent tellement de
surprises par rapport à cette liberté
parce qu'il faut savoir que
contrairement à d'autres pays
le masque n'a pas été comment dire
tellement tellement diffusé et surtout
quel tellement rendu obligatoire même
s'il a été bon on va dire sur le plan
légal
les espagnols eux la tique est assez
particulière et ils savent très bien que
la police ait beaucoup plus intéressés
par l'arrestation de terroristes par
exemple que par l'arrestation jeune
j'allais d'une vieille dame qui a oublié
son masque alors port du masque plus
obligatoire parce que la campagne
vaccinale il faut le dire a été très
très efficace comment il serait l'a fait
pour avoir autant de vaccins
la raison fondamentale pour laquelle
nous avons eu des vaccins c'est que
j'étais pratiquement mis aux enchères et
israël a payé a accepté de payer le prix
fort pour les avoir quantités
importantes avant tout le monde
le calcul au niveau du gouvernement
était simple une journée de confinement
coûte extrêmement cher à l'économie
l'économie israélienne est quand même si
elle d'un tout petit pays par conséquent
vacciner la population le plus
rapidement possible et est extrêmement
important donc je crois des vaccins ont
été payés environ 30 à 40 ans en dessus
du prix habituel permis à israël de
recevoir énormément de doses alors tout
cas suffisamment pour couvrir la
population largement mais il ya aussi un
autre facteur qui était important qu'il
faut noter c'est le système à redon le
système de santé israélien qui est quand
même assez performants notamment au
niveau de la diffusion des produits au
niveau de la diffusion des médicaments
au niveau de l'adulte dire des contrôles
c'est pas un contrôle au niveau de la
commande ira au niveau de l'organisation
de la population et où nous avons ici un
système qui est celui de ton appel eco4
olic
dispensaire ce sont des caisses
complémentaires qui a ajouté un site ou
un siège social et qui ont là la gestion
totale de la santé et ça fait d'une
façon tout à fait tout à fait
remarquable alors à ce que ces savants
la vaccination qui explique la faible
circulation du virus en israël j'ai
évidemment que la vaccination récemment
à jouer un rôle énorme parce que vous
savez qu'on est passé à moins de 200 cas
par jour alors que au mois de janvier on
était à plus de 10000 m les chiffres le
sont là pour les chiffres sont là pour
en parler
rader part indépendamment de cela il ya
aussi j'veux dire une certaine
discipline la part de la population
israélienne à l'exception de certaines
minorités notamment les ultra religieux
et certains villages arabes qui n'ont
pas tellement respecté les consignes
gouvernementales
mais dans la mesure où la gestion a été
plutôt rigoureuse et que l'information
est bien passée les extras guéant le
camp de tendance nous avons eu quand
même tendance à faire confiance au
gouvernement ce n'est pas le g1 passion
le cas dans d'autres pays notamment en
notamment en france et notamment en
europe alors comment se profile la
saison touristique en israël il ya déjà
le passeport vert vaccinale pour les
habitants et pour les voyages en reste
il y aura le passeport vaccinale dès le
23 mai alors on ne sait pas exactement
comment ça va se faire puisque l'on sait
c'est que le gouvernement a annoncé une
réouverture des frontières ou non
israéliens à partir du mode mes genoux
23 comme peut le dire je pense ce qui
veut dire qu'à partir du 23 mai les gens
qui sont vaccinées à l'extérieur donc
dans des pays étrangers et qui ne sont
pas effrayés pour un nouveau revenir et
donc participer le tourisme en israël
alors maintenant est-ce qu'il va y avoir
une exigence d'un passeport vert je ne
sais pas j'ai pas encore lu
l'information sur ce sujet le passeport
qui est en fait pas vraiment un
passeport si vous en avez déjà une
légende bien puisque j'étais vacciner
deux fois je vais vous le montrer c'est
tout simplement un petit objet comme ça
qui est qui se délient et en tout
simplement vous avez danse
dans ce cube dans ce que tu râles code
l'information globale de qui vous êtes
numéro de sécurité sociale etc et du
fait que les invités vacciner jusqu'à
présent je suis allé dans plein
d'endroits puisque tous les restaurants
sont ouverts tous les flics est ouvert
on stagne aujourd'hui à parler cinéma
qui seront ouverts la semaine prochaine
et je n'ai pas encore lu une seule fois
on n'a pas encore demandé de crespin une
seule fois en sachant que si vous n'avez
pas votre placement vers il vous suffit
d'avoir un certificat donc engager enfin
non qu vie d'un certificat attestant que
vous n'avez pas attraper la maladie ont
pour pouvoir vous présenter n'importe où
même manière que nous dit un passeport
merci en tout cas à pierre rappelle que
vous êtes reporter écrivain vous étiez
en direct avec mon depuis tel aviv merci
à vous merci